[Music]
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my brand new batman video for the
flash movie we just got our first
footage of ben affleck's batman there's
a bunch of easter eggs so we'll break it
all down we also know what he's doing in
the other parts of the movie as well so
i'll explain that if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos it's just getting started
we're getting ready for a big dc fandom
event in october that's when we'll be
seeing more footage for the matt reeves
batman movie probably the next big
trailer also probably some sort of
teaser trailer for the flash movie also
explain what's going on during the
timeline of the flash movie here and
where this fits in relative to the
justice league snyder cut ending scenes
the epilogue the post-credits scenes
because they had that whole epilogue
showing all the characters and what they
were doing next right after the events
of the movie and even though i think
everybody understands this if it wasn't
clear the flash movie is directly
connected to the zack snyder dc movies
like justice league batman v superman
man of steel so that's the whole reason
that they're bringing ben affleck's
batman back because they're also doing a
flashpoint story so i know there's a lot
of questions about how much of the
flashpoint story they're doing but if
you weren't aware they've been filming
the flash movie for a good long while
now we've got a whole bunch of teasers
and scenes so far i've done a couple
videos for those so i'll put links in
the description below we've seen ezra
miller's flash inside michael keaton's
batcave just freaking out like wait a
minute what's going on where am i but
what's happening in these new ben
affleck batman scenes that they just
released during the flash movies he's
chasing down these criminals driving
this military spec humvee through the
streets of gotham city if you couldn't
tell from the architecture this is meant
to be gotham city his gotham city on the
justice league earth because this is a
multiverse movie we'll be visiting
multiple versions of earth the whole
thing with ben affleck's batman though
you probably noticed is that the new bat
cycle probably looks familiar it looks
like a combination of the bat cycle from
batman white knight and some unused
concept art from the justice league
snyder cut you may remember zack snyder
had a bat cycle that almost made it into
the movie it's a little bit shorter and
stubbier than this one and it doesn't
use wheels it uses jets to maneuver
around but you can see how zack snyder
thought this out it would have remotely
summoned to him wherever he was and he'd
mount it vertically like this and then
shift it into the horizontal position
and take off he probably couldn't use it
to fly super high in the atmosphere or
anything like a true jet but he could
probably use it to make some pretty
wicked jumps it just seems like andy
muschietti the flash movie people
decided to take a more traditional
approach with their bat cycle but zoom
and enhance it's got two wheels in the
front an extra fat one in the back and
it's covered in the same type of armor
as his ship the batmobile from justice
league snyder cut it's made from the
same material makes sense it was also
the very frank miller dark knight
returns bat tank from the end of the
justice league snyder cut 2. you have to
imagine that that exists somewhere in
this world too the version of the batman
suit that it looks like he's wearing is
slightly tuned up hybrid of his batman v
superman leather armor suit the frank
miller looking dark knight return suit
in the hardcore armor suit from justice
league like a lighter weight suit with
extra armor laid on top to protect his
arms back exposed areas while he's
riding the bat cycle you can also see
the scaled looking armor plating
protecting his spine at his back and
even though you don't see his cape he
could be going capeless yes but my early
guesses is that they're just doing the
cape as a special effect because it's
easier to film that way they're also
doing the exact same thing for
supergirl's cape in the movie too if you
haven't seen the supergirl scenes that
were released earlier this year you can
see her during a couple different scenes
a fight scene and then just a regular
scene of her floating in the air and
while she's on the wires here being
hoisted up as if she were flying there's
a couple of these moments where she
doesn't have a cape on set just because
they're gonna add it with special
effects later if you don't remember zack
snyder often did the same thing for
henry cavill superman scenes when he was
doing a fight scene or there was a lot
of action he would just go capeless and
then add the cape later with special
effects the design language of her
superman suit her crest is the same as
henry cavill superman it just tunes
slightly differently in the color scheme
of her suit looks a little bit more like
the injustice super girl suit they
haven't completely explained whether or
not she comes from michael keaton batman
earth or if she's going to come from
somewhere else in the multiverse or if
she comes from the main justice league
earth we'll probably find out about that
when they release the first trailer the
reason why i think this ben affleck
scene might be happening earlier in the
movie is just because i think they want
to show you the things for ben affleck's
batman after the events of the justice
league snyder cut post credit scene or
just business as usual in gotham like
they're not gonna do any of the huge
overarching plot from the justice league
sequels in the flash movie like the big
dark side stuff that they were teasing
they'll probably reference some of the
previous adventures they had like
fighting aliens just a little while ago
but i think a little time will have gone
by and he's just been doing his regular
batman crime fighting activities since
the end of justice league like what
better way to convey that than to
introduce him in the movie in the middle
of a chase scene or a fight scene with
him being full batman just business as
usual going around beating the crap out
of criminals the other big thing that
andy muschietti the director said
they're doing with his batman in the
movie is that ben affleck's batman is
going to give the flash his brand new
flash suit like he'll build it for him
the one that they showed off in the
teaser at dc fandom last year i'm just
gonna call that his multiverse suit for
now as you can see it's a huge upgrade
you can see the speed force energy
arcing all over it it looks a little bit
more comic booky i'm assuming that a lot
of this will be done with special
effects and that's probably why we
haven't seen him wearing it around in
broad daylight yet they also said that
ben affleck's batman has this huge
emotional component of the movie my
assumption is that that's part of the
flashpoint storyline with the death of
barry's mother because batman lost both
of his parents and obviously because we
have michael keaton's batman who has
pretty much the exact same backstory he
lost both his parents as well in crime
alley just like ben affleck's batman i
don't know if they're gonna do the
actual letter scene to sort of tag
things at the end from the comic book in
the animated justice league flashpoint
movie but in that original story it was
thomas wayne his father batman's father
who wrote him the letter what they might
wind up doing early theory is that
they'll just do a twist on that where
michael keaton's older batman writes his
younger self ben affleck's batman a
version of that letter why is old batman
writing his younger self some advice on
life i know a lot of people are
wondering if this is going to be ben
affleck's last time as batman my
assumption now is never say never but i
think for now they'll just end the movie
he will still be batman on the main
justice league earth it's not like
they're going to kill him off or retcon
him or anything like that so i wouldn't
worry about that kind of stuff you may
remember just a little while ago too
there was a bunch of special trailer
footage that leaked out and yes i did
see it but i can't put it in this video
it just shows the flash in his new flash
suit teaming up with michael keaton's
batman who's in a version of the bat pod
his jet from the batman 1989 movie also
with supergirl all of them teaming up
for a big fight scene there were a lot
of other scenes that they showed inside
michael keaton's bat cave with them
walking around it looks like an upgraded
version of the batcave scenes from the
batman 1989 movie as you would expect i
think they'll release that footage at
the new dc fandom event happening in
october this year this is him as bruce
wayne towards the end of the movie at
the central city courthouse steps as
ezra miller's flash comes out with iris
west at the end of his father's trial
and after they've cleared his name in
the death of barry's mother because
that's obviously a big part of the film
too barry's still trying to get his
father out of prison supergirl is also
here in this scene too barry seems happy
that's why everyone thinks this is from
later in the movie as opposed to the
beginning of the movie if you're not a
car person either that new car that
michael keaton's bruce wayne is driving
this is a brand new mercedes-maybach
model so batman driving really expensive
really cool cars has always been a thing
michael keane's batman obviously coming
from the earth where all the tim burton
batman movies took place i'm just going
to call that the burton verse for now we
could also call that earth 89 that's
what they did during crisis on infinite
earth and because of the ezra miller
grant gustin crossover scene from crisis
on infinite earths you could say that
all of that is canon to the justice
league multiverse that they're doing in
the flash movie everything is canon now
because of the multiverse we joke but
that's kind of the concept that they
were talking about during the last big
dc fandom event last year when they
released the first teaser trailer for
the movie during that crisis on infinite
earth scene they just had a michael
keaton batman earth 89 cameo scene that
was robert wole's alexander knox from
the batman 1989 movie reading the gotham
globe newspaper from the movie there
were also a bunch of other scenes and
big easter eggs that didn't make it into
the actual episodes like this other
newspaper saying that he was about to
get married to selena kyle's catwoman
and if you don't remember the other
things they've said about michael
keaton's batman in the movie what
they've explained is the movie will
treat batman forever and batman and
robin as if those movies happen in
another reality they're just using the
events of the tim burton batman movies
for michael keaton's batman continuity
in his timeline maybe if things go well
they do more sequels to the flash movie
we'll see more michael keaton batman
characters from his earth come back like
michelle pfeiffer made it seem like she
would love to come back as catwoman but
i don't think that she's supposed to be
in this new flash movie right now the
movie is scheduled to come out in
november next year so we'll see more
trailers and footage later this year and
also a lot of footage for the matt
reeves batman movie i think i'm allowed
to post my suicide squad movie review
this wednesday the embargo should be up
make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss that i will do
more suicide squad videos as the movie
starts to come out once you do have a
chance to see it make sure you write
your reactions in the comments below but
please do not post spoilers everyone
click here for my new loki video all
about how iron man knew about kang in
the mcu and click here to learn about
the full plot of what justice league
snyder cut 2 and justice league 3 would
have been thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you